We've had practice finding the equations of horizontal and vertical lines, as
well as finding the equations of lines given two points or given a point and a
slope. This last problem, we're going to look at parallel and perpendicular
lines. So, this last problem, we want to find the equation of a line. The first
line goes through the point 2,4 and is parallel to the line 3x plus y equals 7.
For the first problem, find the equation of the line that goes through the point
2,4 and is parallel to the line 3x plus y equals 7. For the second equation,
find the equation of the line that goes through the point 2,4 and is
perpendicular to the line 3x plus y equals 7. You can put your answers here and
put them in slope-intercept form.